>> Stephan: OK, hi and welcome back to another
VC libraries, Open code review.
Umm today we'll be looking at PR 1794.
Use iterator concept in vector's range
constructor. A PR from our
contributor Adam Bucior.
This is fixing an issue that we had filed
by a user a little bit over a year ago.
And this is about, Umm,
constructing a std::vector
from a range of iterators,
so let me give you some background
on how this works and then we can
look at the issue and the PR itself.
So here I'm opening up the latest
draft copy of the C++ standard
and let's go to containers,
sequence containers and then vector.
Let's just look at the class
definition here.
And zoom in.
A little bit of a core language note
when I say class definition that
refers to the stuff starting from class
here or template class all the way
down to the closing brace semi colon.
All the declarations of type
defs and constructors and member
functions and so forth.
And the standard name for
that is class definition.
Even though most programmers would
refer to that as a declaration,
it's actually defining the class,
and it's a layout because the data
members are there and and so forth.
Sometimes learning how the core language
or compilers refer to things helps you
understand how to read the standard itself.
So vectors got a bunch of constructors,
and of course member functions not
quite as many as std::string.
The one we're interested in looks
like this here.
So I can actually.
Why don't we use compiler Explorer?
I can maybe give a quick tour
of how this works. Let's see,
this should hopefully be big enough. OK,
I don't want that compiler option for sure.
OK, so we've got like a vector.
Maybe I'll include some other examples here.
List and iterator.
And iostream.
Yes. And maybe.
A string OK, this is not quite sorted order.
It's good enough.
OK, so let's have our example.
Have a print function.
I'm just going to use a vector
because I don't really care
about the element type here,
but this of course applies to all elements.
That's inspect everything in the vec.
And print out that element.
That's not going to work.
This maybe just spaces. I'm here. OK.
So we can have a vector of int I see.
Let's start with the things
I want to demonstrate.
Are what if you have?
One vector. Call this.
Odd numbers
1, 3, 5, 7, 9, 11, 13, 15 and so forth.
And I can just make temporary
vectors when I print.
So print what if we want to print a
vector construct from on odds.begin() + 2
odds.end() - 2,
that is a thing that I can do OK.
See if this all compiles.
Hopefully this is big enough to see.
Let me know.
That's actually kind of tiny,
maybe temporarily increased
the zoom to 200 here.
OK, hopefully this should
be a little bit visible.
OK, So what this code is doing?
I start off with vector.
I'm going to call this one
odds just contains a bunch of odd numbers.
I can then construct temporary
temporary vector from a
subrange of this other vector.
I can say hey,
I want to start at odds.begin() + 2,
so skip those first two elements and
I want to end at odds.end() - 2.
So skip the last two elements
so I should get 5, 7, 9 and 11,
and indeed that is what's printed out,
so we refer to this as vector
range constructor because
it's constructed from a range,
possibly the entire range of
some other container or array
or some arbitrary subrange.
In this case I'm using a
subrange of another vector,
but I'm not limited to constructing
from the exact same container type
and the exact same element type.
This would also work if this
were a vector of short,
so I can change this over to vector.
It will recompile and I still get 5, 7, 9 and 11,
so I'm going to construct.
My vector from a subrange of
vector. Every short element
in the original odds vector will
be widened to an int element here.
But again,
I'm not restricted to the actual
container type being the same.
I could have a list of shorts so
I could actually just change this
in place to list and this will
compile and this is no longer
working because I said plus.
So here I can use helper functions,
there is next,
which is a helper function in the
iterator header that will advance
an iterator by a given amount.
It can also advance backwards so I
can convert both of these to say next.
The reason why is that random
access iterators.
Provide operator plus and operator minus,
but bidirectional iterators don't
because it would be too tempting
to compile something and this has
to be negative, not positive.
Otherwise bad things will happen.
There we go.
OK,
so I've successfully translated
the code over to a list of short so
I can take an arbitrary subrange,
and in this case I'm grabbing
from a bidirectional linked list,
but I can give even weaker iterators,
so if I have a.
istringstream because I'm going
to read from it.
iss construct from and let's say 1,3,5,7,9,
11, 13, 15, 17.
This case I don't want to do
this subrange thing.
But what if I have an istream_iterator?
I can read shorts from this
from iss and then the same type but
empty braces for the end iterator.
Let's see if I remember my iostreams
and does this work if I not counted
the correct number of braces.
Apparently I have. I forgot
to semi colon here.
OK, that compiles and there we go.
So here I have an istringstream
iss that I have constructed from
a string with a bunch of space
separated odd numbers and I can use an
istream_iterator to parse integers.
In this case I'm saying I want to read
short values from this istringstream
until I run out of them and
the end istream_iterator is a default
constructed one or value constructed one,
value initialized and this will
indeed read all of the values as shorts.
from the istringstring.
So what's happening here is
actually kind of interesting.
I'm giving the vector the
weakest possible range of iterators.
These are input iterators and as
a refresher for those who are new
to the stl iterator strength
hierarchy for reading,
you've got input iterators,
and you've got forward.
You've got bidirectional.
You've got random access,
and in C++20 you have something even
stronger which are contiguous iterators.
That are like pointers and vectors and
string iterators and things like that.
So if you have input iterators,
the thing that you're giving up
is the ability to make multiple
passes over the input data,
because as you're incrementing an
istream_iterator, you're consuming
information from that stringstream
and as soon as you increment
that istream_iterator,
you can't go back and read
previously obtained values.
This is relevant to vector because
for forward and stronger iterators,
vector can do something cool it can say OK,
because I can make multiple passes
over this input data if I have a
first iterator and a last iterator,
I can determine the distance between them.
If it's random access or better,
I can just subtract them and get that
distance in constant time if it's forward.
Or bidirectional only I can increment
from the first to the last count
how many times I had to increment,
and that's the number of elements,
and then I can allocate exactly
that much memory and I don't need
to repeatedly resize.
This is efficient,
much better than repeatedly reallocating
and transferring elements over,
but if I'm constructed from an
input only range like the case here,
I don't know how many elements they're
going to be attempting to find that
would actually consume the elements,
and I'm not ready to do that so.
Here the vector is no choice but to
repeatedly in place back elements
and geometrically reallocate,
which is efficient but not as efficient
as allocating the whole size up front.
So this is what we're going
to be looking at today.
So end of refresher,
let's take a look at this issue
which I have not memorized,
so I'll be reading it.
The user says the stl loses the
iterator category when range iterators
are passed to the vector constructor.
Consider the following code.
So here we have C++20 ranges
with some namespace aliases.
sr is std::ranges, rv is sr::views
Two vector takes a random
access range and gets the
begin and end from it and then makes a
std::vector of that value type. Then here
we start with the std::vector using
class template argument deduction.
So this is a vector of int storing 1,2,3,4,5.
We're passing this or piping it
through a ranges views transform that
takes every element of that vector.
Here v means value, not vector really
and then converts it to a float.
So we are going to transform this
range of ints to a range of floats
and we should get a vector out.
So the user says currently STL
containers,
lack constructors accepting ranges.
I think there's an upcoming paper.
Or actually I think it's in our.
Let me see Casey's in this meeting so
he'll be able to correct me if I forget it.
I'm thinking of ranges too.
1206 OK.
OK, so we can look at the stl projects
C++23 features.
And I'm thinking of.
Ohh is that this one here?
Conversions of ranges to containers
>> Casey: [unintelligible]
>> Casey: of all because I've got it mostly
implemented and I'm perennially
>> Casey: 5% away from getting it finished.
>> Stephan: Excellent.
So we will be reviewing this at
some point in the future,
so there was machinery coming in C++23
that will make this even easier to do.
I'll just bring up the paper here real quick.
Conversions from ranges to containers.
Surprisingly,
a coauthor is Casey Carter.
So thank you for looking at that.
We don't have the paper yet,
so that's why this user saying
currently stl containers
lack constructors accepting ranges.
And so here the user says that we
are calling eventually an internal
machinery as indicated by these
underscore capital ugly names.
It's invoking vector's
_Range_construct_or_tidy from input iterators.
So we have lost the iterator category.
The interesting thing here is that in C++98
through 17 we had only
iterator categories.
These were the input iterator tag,
forward iterator tag,
bidirectional iterator tag,
random access iterator tag.
in C++20 with the
addition of ranges we gained iterator
concept which is related to but
different from the iterator category.
In particular,
you can express contiguous iterators
with the iterator concept.
I'm being a little bit vague here
because I haven't completely memorized
how all this stuff works.
Eventually I'll learn how this stuff works,
slowly internalizing it.
I'm much more familiar with
the old way of doing things,
in C++17 and before,
so the user has found a very valid
issue here that we have something
that should be pretty strong.
We have a random access range,
but vectors older implementation is
only detecting these things as input
iterators and using the fall back
mechanism of calling in place back in
a loop so it ends up being correct.
It will correct in the sense of it
actually does allocate the elements and
we get everything transferred over,
but it's less efficient than necessary.
And then here,
on the other hand,
calling 2 vector and passing
a correctly dispatches to the
forward iterator tag version.
So that is what Adam Bucior is fixing here.
So let's take a look at the code.
This is a relatively small change,
only 64 additions, 17
deletions, so it's a relatively small tweak,
but it is affecting the most
important container in the entire STL,
which I claim is vector and not string,
so we need to be very careful
about correctness,
performance and all that stuff.
Vector is surprisingly complicated,
so I have merged main into this PR,
so we're looking at the most modern
context. We have recently thanks to
our contributors almost completely
overhauled the STL to use if constexpr
instead of tag dispatch,
so this code is much easier to read
than it used to be years ago.
So here we can see vector's
range constructor.
I hope that this is big enough.
Yeah, I've used 150% for other reviews.
Let me know if this looks too small.
So vector's range constructor.
were templated on arbitrary iterators.
We've got a constraint here,
expressed through enable_if
that these things have to
at least look like iterators.
This is something that goes back to C++98
and has been refined since then.
This helps this constructor avoid
being ambiguous with vectors
and copies of T constructor,
because if you're constructing from
like 5 copies of 1729, we don't want.
iter to be deduced to be int.
That would be bad.
So this constraint says, hey,
you at least need to kind
of resemble an iterator.
In particular,
you can't be an arithmetic
type or an integral type,
so that's what that constraint is doing.
And then at this point we're just
templated on some arbitrary iterator type.
We don't know how strong it is,
so the code originally here was using
one of our helper variable templates,
saying if you're a forward iterator.
Or better then we can take it the
distance between these iterators.
After doing our iterator unwrapping,
which we'll do iterator checking and
unwrap down to raw pointers if we
recognize oh you're a vector or an iterator
or something and we don't need to pay
that checking cost over and over,
so that's what that you first
and you last are doing.
So going back if we have a
forward iterator or stronger,
we can call std::distance,
which is a generalized helper
function that will subtract.
If they are random access iterators
or increment from first to last to
count the number of elements between
forward or bidirectional iterators.
And once we have how many
elements there are in the range,
we can allocate that much memory and
then construct from that range of elements.
But in the old code, if we don't
have forward or stronger iterators,
we must be working with the
weakest input iterators,
in which case we need to repeatedly
reallocate by calling in place
in a loop.
So that's what this code is doing,
plus some iterator debugging stuff and.
Tidying in case allocation fails for some
reason because we are in the constructor.
So what Adam Bucior is adding here
is concepts powered logic. so #ifdef
__cpp_lib_concepts
will activate this only in C++20 and
above when concepts are enabled as a
separate unrelated thing that will
eventually become just if has the C++20.
As an aside and this says if we
are not a classic forward iterator
according to the iterator
category,
but if at compile time we meet
the forward iterator concept,
then we can do some cool stuff.
So that's what this is doing.
The question was raised when
we first briefly looked at this
during the maintainers meeting.
Aren't these the same and
they are not quite the same.
There are iterators that meet the
forward iterator concept that
do not that aren't marked with
the forward iterator category.
Oh, Nicole, go ahead.
>> Nicole: Sorry, I'm I'm still sick.
>> Nicole: Uh, so that's why I sound terrible,
>> Nicole: but my point in the meeting
>> Nicole: yesterday was less, uh,
>> Nicole: aren't these the same and more?
>> Nicole: Uh, should _Is_fwd_iter_v uh,
>> Nicole: be like only done in old code.
>> Nicole: Given that I believe that forward iterator
>> Nicole: like encompasses _Is_fwd_iter_v?
>> Nicole: Does that make sense?
>> Stephan: Yeah, OK, so the question is
not is it redundant
but could we simply replace
the old code path?
>> Nicole: Right. And like obviously we would need to
>> Nicole: like do an ifdef and then and else,
>> Nicole: but in theory it's.
>> Nicole: Reasonable,
>> Nicole: I think everything that is a forward iterator
>> Nicole: in C++ or C++17 classic forward iterator,
>> Nicole: whatever is also a forward
>> Nicole: iterator in the new ranges world.
>> Nicole: I might be wrong though Casey.
>> Stephan: Yeah, I'll let.
I'll let Casey comment there.
My initial reaction is that I think
we may need to worry about iterators
that essentially lie and they're tagged
with _Is_fwd_iter_v without, um not
technically meeting the requirements.
In particular,
I think Casey mentioned.
Uh, that the forward iterator concept.
Let see the forward iterator concept allows iterators
that don't return true references.
The classic forward iterator
tag or category technically
does require true references,
but there are types like
I think regex iterators.
That don't really meet the requirements,
but they claim to be
forward iterators anyway,
and this code actually works,
so I would be worried about.
Affecting the behavior of existing code,
but I'll let Casey comment how close.
How close did we get?
Casey may have stepped away
from his computer, so that's OK,
>> Casey: Sorry. I'm I'm here. I I didn't.
>> Casey: I was muted. Apologies.
>> Casey: I think all actual things that comply
>> Casey: with CPP 17 forward iterator will
>> Casey: actually satisfy the forward iter concept,
>> Casey: and I did just look at this.
>> Casey: Right like moments ago because I was
>> Casey: trying to make sure that it was kosher
>> Casey: for us to check forward iterator on
>> Casey: things that were CPP 17 input iterators,
>> Casey: which it is because yeah,
>> Casey: we checked that they've opted in
>> Casey: by the iter concept value first,
>> Casey: so it's clean.
>> Casey: We can do this under as if and I
>> Casey: actually had that concern with this PR,
>> Casey: but it's fine.
>> Casey: so the question now can we get
>> Casey: rid of the old path and you are
>> Casey: right that there are broken iterator
>> Casey: types that will use the old path.
>> Casey: Still that wouldn't make the new path.
>> Stephan: OK, so in an ideal world we could
do Nicole's suggests and just
use forward iterator concept for C++20
and above but old code broken code
would possibly some in the standard
itself would interfere with that.
So here because vector is so central.
I think this approach is good as is we
could potentially in the future explore.
OK like how many iterators would
be broken by such a change.
But I think that being noninvasive
is probably the right approach here,
because this PR as it stands,
is only trying to improve performance.
If we tried to replace this old code path,
the advantage would be perhaps a little
bit of throughput that we wouldn't
need to test this additional condition,
but this should be quite cheap to check.
And if we did eliminate this and start
changing behavior for broken iterators,
then this would become more impactful.
So I'm inclined to leave this code
as is in the PR and simply add the
additional else if constexpr under
__cpp_lib_concepts. But I'm definitely.
I'm interesting to look at.
OK, I see Nicole's giving us thumbs up.
OK,
so we're returning back to this code
if we have __cpp_lib_concepts
then we can chain in
an additional else if constexpr
and if we meet the forward iterator
concept then we can essentially
do what we did before.
We're also going to have
const auto _Count except instead of calling
std::distance we're gonna call
ranges distance since that will be
capable of handling forward iterator.
Here we do have an assumption that.
And this is very similar to the original
code that if the incoming user defined
iter meets the forward iterator concept,
then surely we can call ranges
distance on the unwrapped form.
And I believe that holds because we
control the unwrapping machinery and
essentially if an iterator participates
in the unwrapping scheme
then the unwrapped version needs to
be at least as strong as the user
defined wrapped iterator coming in,
so that looks fine.
This calls ranges distance and
then whatever that is.
That in general will be something
like a ptrdiff_t or a signed type.
But what we do is if the
iterators have passed our check.
Our ADL verify range then
we don't want to sign type.
We know that it's non negative
so we should be able to static
cast to size_t and then we've got
a helper function convert size
that will potentially narrow it
down to the allocators size type.
Casey, go ahead.
>> Casey: We can't static cast the results of
>> Casey: ranges distance to size_t without
>> Casey: possibly losing information.
>> Stephan: Since, like the iota with 128 bit
>> Stephan: or whatever stuff,
>> Casey: yes
>> Casey: there it's possible that ranges have
>> Casey: integer class type for their size type,
>> Casey: which has values that aren't
>> Casey: representable by size_t,
>> Casey: and we'll be modulating the information
>> Casey: away and that would be bad.
>> Casey: So what we need to do here is instead
>> Casey: of static casting the size_t,
>> Casey: we need to use _To_unsigned_like.
>> Casey: Internal helper function
>> Stephan: Let's see if I can find that I do have my.
Enlistment here or repo.
OK so you said _To_unsigned_like_t?
>> Casey: No t
>> Stephan: I didn't get it right.
>> Stephan: Oh, no t. There we go.
_To_unsigned_like OK,
>> Stephan: that lives in xutility.
>> Casey: lives in xutility.
>> Stephan: Yeah, OK, great.
And this is is this only suit?
Yeah, this is clearly concepts lands,
so we shouldn't be using this in old code.
But we should use it a new code.
OK, that's 476 ish.
OK let me get the citation here.
stl, inc,
xutility,
_To_unsigned_like, hit Y for permalink.
OK, and I'll copy the whole thing.
OK, this is. It is mostly, no.
I shouldn't say, mostly, UM.
This would be observable because
if I have let me see if I can
get the right scenario here.
If I have one of those iota views where I am
going iota from some enormous range, UM.
What would that be that would be?
I have to be able to get something
that's bigger than 64 bit, right?
Oh no, it would be.
It would be like iota view of here we go.
Iota view of unsigned long
long on a 32 bit system.
I can totally do that here.
The range of distance would be like a
64 bit distance or something static
cast to size T would be modular.
So even though I can't really represent
over 32 bits physically in memory
iota view can make 64 bit stuff.
Did Nicole did
you have your hand up briefly?
>> Nicole: Ohh yeah, I was just gonna say,
>> Nicole: I assume that the convert size throws a.
>> Nicole: Throws an exception if the thing is too big.
>> Nicole: Why this is good?
>> Nicole: Like the basically what what?
>> Nicole: What will happen in the modulo case is?
>> Nicole: You'll get a
>> Nicole: bad codegen where or bad code where you like.
>> Nicole: Create, uh? Uh.
>> Nicole: Create a thing that's like if you have
>> Nicole: a range from zero to two to the uh,
>> Nicole: 33 you create a range of zero and then
>> Nicole: construct n into that range of 0.
>> Nicole: Which is obviously broken.
>> Stephan: Yeah
>> Nicole: and what you want is
>> Nicole: that the this is too big.
>> Nicole: My question is, isn't this broken
>> Nicole: in the other code as well?
>> Nicole: Like my understanding is that std::distance
>> Nicole: On something similar to an iota of
>> Nicole: you could still exist in C++17.
>> Nicole: I guess. I guess it wouldn't be a.
>> Nicole: It wouldn't be a forward iterator range,
>> Nicole: though it would be an input iterator.
>> Nicole:Never mind, right.
>> Casey: Right, it wouldn't.
>> Casey: We're protected by the fact that this
>> Casey: is for working on forward iterators,
>> Casey: and they have to refer to
>> Casey: actual objects in memory,
>> Casey: so we're basically guaranteed
>> Casey: that no forward range is has a
>> Casey: distance longer than size_t, right?
>> Stephan: OK so I'm looking at convert size
convert size expects its input to be
whoops input to be size_t and then
this is really intended to handle
what if I'm in like X64 so size_t
64 bit But I've got some 32 bits
something allocator.
Then I need to convert down to the
allocator size type that could overflow,
so that's what this check is doing.
But if the allocator size type is size_t,
this just becomes a no op,
so that's what convert size does,
so we should be using _To_unsigned_like here.
And then. Going down to convert size,
do we need like a handwritten check basically?
Because the input still
may not be size type.
Let me bring up the _To_unsigned_like that
was here and then close some of these.
The bug OK, this just converts
over to the unsigned counterpart.
But then we still need to get to.
We never want to accidentally truncate,
so I think we need a handwritten check.
Is that right? Essentially doing what
convert size is doing, but handwritten?
>> Casey: I just pasted convert size from
my P1206 branch
>> Casey: into the chat.
>> Stephan: OK, you've got.
>> Stephan: You've got just the right code.
>> Casey: which does the right thing.
There's your code,
I cannot read it because the chat is
literally like 10 characters wide,
which is frustrating.
It's on my other screen, which is
why you can't see it on the the view.
OK, so you've generalized in your code.
Convert size to handle this.
>> Casey: Yes
>> Stephan: That's interesting. OK, so for this PR.
>> Casey: So yeah, I can get a link if you want a link
```suggestion
>> Casey: But yeah, this PR is going to need to.
>> Casey: We need that that convert size
>> Casey: change one way or another,
>> Casey: so maybe with this we should
>> Casey: hold this up until applying P1206
>> Stephan: The other thing we could do
is we could just say this is a
corner case for like iota views.
Merge this as is and then
patch it up in 1206.
I would be OK with that if this
is sufficiently obscure because
it is really quite extreme.
It's something that only happens
with extremely large iota views,
which hopefully I mean.
On the other hand it is vector
if you don't want to.
>> Casey: Or user-defined range types.
They can define their own range types
that use or size so.
Yeah, Nicole's questioning the chat.
Does MSVC support 32 bit
protected mode segmentation?
I believe the answer is no.
We always have flat memory
models for all of our platforms,
so we don't I think have to
worry about things like that.
OK, so thinking range's distance is
returning some sign type we can use.
_To_unsigned_like to get to
the unsigned counterpart,
but then we need to worry about
getting down to the size type.
I guess the other thing is we
could use a handwritten check here
to be strictly correct and then
replace that with Casey's new
function in 1206,
and have his PR do that and after
that everything is fine here.
I think I might be.
I might suggest that.
Yeah, actually Casey can you.
Can you send the link so I can at
least bring it up on the screen
so I can show our viewers and the
recording what we're talking about.
OK, that'll be faster than navigating there.
I think I think probably that may be the
best approach just so we never have a
even a short time in Microsoft STL main
that is doing the wrong thing when we
know what the right thing is to do. I'm OK,
so we do need to mention unsigned like.
Let's see if I can capture the
entire discussion. In the UM?
Original _Is_fwd_iter_v code path.
We're guaranteed to be looking at,
uh, real elements. Or looking at UM?
We're guaranteed that the
source range consists of
real references to memory so the
distance will always fit in size_t.
However in the new
forward iterator code path. The.
Let me say std::distance here
to be clear the ranges distance
might be larger than size_t,
for example, iota_view. For example,
a 64 bit iota_view on a 32 bit
architecture. Uhm?
The static_cast
might therefore truncate. OK.
We need. 2 steps here.
OK, Casey's got the link and then Nicole asks,
are we concerned about broken iterator types,
IE stashing iterators?
I think what the concept?
Iterators are really they.
Even if they were tending to like lie
with the original categories when they
satisfy the concept, we should. Ohh,
the question is for the non concept code.
There it's like we grudgingly tolerate them.
Generally we will knockout go out of
our way to try to make stuff work,
but if the natural loop happens
to work with broken iterators,
then we accept them.
Which is why they they end up working
like regex iterators they will,
I think work with this even though they
return values from inside themselves
because we don't do something like
grab a reference from an iterator,
increment it and then try to
use the original reference,
even if that technically should
work according to the iterator
strength requirements.
The vector has no reason to do that,
so users get away with
such stashing iterators.
Which is weird, but it works.
OK, so we need to steps here first is.
The _To_unsigned_like.
OK. Um. 1) Call _To_unsigned_like
to convert the signed distance type to
its unsigned counterpart. And then
2) Convert. That unsigned like type to
the allocators size type. Which might
need to throw a length error. Uhm?
Casey Carter's branch for what's the
the issue number I should have?
Shouldn't have closed it?
>> Stephan: The projects classic.
>> Casey: I can tell
>> Casey: you the proposal number.
>> Stephan: OK. 2532
>> Stephan: Contains such. Machinery.
Yeah, that will cite.
This here I see just static assert,
some basic things that
they have to be unsigned,
and then if it's too big.
Yeah, so would you recommend?
Since you copy pasting this or just
doing the if constexpr,
>> Casey: yeah that would be fine.
>> Casey: If they go ahead and steal this.
>> Casey: into that PR.
>> Stephan: OK
>> Casey: Yeah benign merge conflict.
>> Stephan: OK Casey Carter recommends just
copying that function into your.
into this PR and.
Which, will result in a
trivial merge conflict to
deal with later.
OK, let's preview this.
If it looks right. OK,
in the original _Is_fwd_iter_v code path.
We're guaranteed that the source range
consists of real references to memory,
so the std::distance will
always fit in size_t. However,
in the new forward iterator code path,
the range's distance might be
larger than size_t, for example,
64 bit iota_view on a 32 bit architecture.
The static_cast
might therefore truncate.
We need 2 steps here,
one called _To_unsigned_like to convert
the signed distance type to its unsigned
counterpart to convert that unsigned
like type to the allocator size type,
which might need to throw a length
error. Casey Carter's branch for
conversions from ranges to containers
contains such machinery.
Oh, we don't get the auto preview
because it's just some random
branch rather than our own.
OK, but we got the citation.
>> Casey: That's unfortunate... I hit y to make sure it was a permalink
>> Stephan: yeah, the fork is not... the repo itself.
Yeah, Casey recommends just
copying the function to this PR,
which will result in a trivial
merge conflict to deal with later.
OK, yeah, I'd be fine with that.
And you added this to what?
xmemory, yeah, good enough.
>> Casey: It's already in xmemory, right
>> Casey: I've just updated the implementation
>> Casey: of convert size.
>> Stephan: Oh I see.
OK yeah, because you're linked to the
branch and not to the diff. OK, cool.
OK, we got a first comment here, great.
Now onward. And that's about.
It's about it. This it doesn't
duplicate the construct in line.
There's no good way to really avoid that.
It's just one line.
Yep, that's good. OK and then.
This here is being.
Changed from tag dispatch to
if constexpr. Where's that happening?
That's happening down here, OK.
We're essentially if constexpr
dispatching,
because we are still calling
a helper function.
How big are these helper functions?
They're pretty big.
Having them separate is fine.
OK,
so previously we overloaded insert
range and internal private ugly helper
function with input iterator tag.
Now it's being renamed to _Insert_input_range.
I like that if we don't need to
distinguish an overload resolution
having a different name makes
it clear what's happening.
No ABI concerns or anything.
OK, so that's good, same forward
range
but the forward range one is being enhanced.
Previously we always just used up
this going to need the same thing.
We always used to take the distance because
we're inserting instead of constructing.
Take the distance and convert over.
Now we have two code paths.
We're going to definitely
initialize a size type.
Count, so that's not changing.
It's definitely initialized,
so it's OK for it to be uninitialized here.
If we're in cpp lib concepts mode ifdef,
then if we're forward iterator concept,
then this is the code that we'll
need to change accordingly.
Otherwise, do the classic thing.
Which is not changing at all.
OK, how many occurrences of this?
I'll just say Ditto below.
I'll just say occurs below cause it
clearly does occur several times.
Edit. Occurs below for insertion, et cetera.
OK yeah, once we get those helper functions,
each line will be quite systematic so it
should end up being a pretty small change.
OK. Next I was wondering, should
we request test coverage for that?
It definitely is going to throw an exception.
I think asking for test coverage
is reasonable because this is a
should be pretty easy to test,
you just make a 60.
Well, it's easy to test on 32
bit architectures on 64 bit
architectures it's annoying.
OK, now I'm less inclined
to ask for test coverage.
OK, I think just inspecting
the coach should be fine.
I am lazy that way.
OK, so returning to the insert
forward range if the concepts end
of concepts if forward iterator.
Then we activate the new stuff.
Otherwise, we already know we satisfy
the original forward iterator tag.
OK, that looks good,
and this avoids repeating the code.
Yep, that's our usual convention, OK then.
This is the call site in insert
some iterator or insert where and
then an arbitrary iterator range.
Previously all we always
just called insert range.
But we tag dispatched here.
And now we're going to have a bool.
And then use if constexpr
to switch between them.
OK, so ifdef __cpp_lib_concepts
above yes below no and if no
OK constexpr bool _Is_fwd
If we either meet the classic
_Is_fwd_iter_v or we meet
the forward iterator concepts.
So this ensures if you met the classic
requirement we will still activate it.
This is safe.
I like this. If we don't have concepts
then only check _Is_fwd_iter_v
OK,
I see no good way to extract this or
anything other than like a horrible
putting or is forward iterator and concepts.
It's fine to just repeat the
_Is_fwd line like this.
This is more readable anyways.
So then, if constexpr (_Is_fwd)
then call the forward range,
otherwise call input range.
We have not.
This doesn't result in multiple lines.
There's no reason to ask like
extract these in any variables.
It's fine to just repeat it
and wrap first and last.
It's fine then,
otherwise make iterator offset OK.
That's good,
same transformation being applied
to assign where we're saying.
Just replace the entire vector with
this range, assign input range,
assign forward range.
OK stuff's happening here.
This looks horrible because
the white space change let me
turn on ignore white space.
Come back to assign forward range.
That should look better.
Indeed, it looks much better.
OK, so assign forward range no
longer taking the tag again,
we're going to have a size type new
size that's going to definitely
be initialized here. Yeah Nicole
>> Nicole: sorry I was just wanted to say it seems.
>> Nicole: I mean. Maybe I'm. Over.
>> Nicole: I don't know, uh, but I think it
>> Nicole: might be nice if this was just one
>> Nicole: function assign range and then we if
>> Nicole: constexpr it in assign range.
>> Nicole: So as well as insert range so that
>> Nicole: we don't have this _Is_fwd copied
>> Nicole: across all of these different places.
>> Stephan: Um. So you're suggesting fuse assign
>> Stephan: forward range and assign input range
>> Stephan: into the caller or something larger?
>> Nicole: Like Fuse, assign forward range and
>> Nicole: assign range together uh and then
>> Nicole: in the caller you can just call
>> Nicole: assign range and it's fine. Uh, I I.
>> Nicole: I don't know if that's good, that's bad.
>> Nicole: That's just something that I
>> Nicole: like saw and I was like, uh,
>> Nicole: that seems like it would be good to do.
>> Stephan: Yeah, that was that was something I asked
very briefly when I saw this for the insert.
Basically, if we're using if constexpr,
why do we still need separate functions here,
given that there's only one caller?
And I think that these are large.
That's the thing.
Like insert forward range.
It's a large function,
it's doing a lot of work.
>> Nicole: That's a very good point.
>> Nicole: I did not notice how big that function was.
>> Stephan: Yeah,
>> Nicole: Never mind I take it back
>> Stephan: the context is hiding a lot
>> Stephan: Yeah, there's a little bit of duplication
where like it sets up my data and stuff,
but I think it would be in
general harder to read that way.
OK, but it is something to think about.
If these functions were substantially
smaller or if they had more useful
duplication that could be extracted,
there would be an argument
for fully inlining them.
And that is something we
can do in the future.
>> Casey: I appreciate if we keep them separate.
>> Casey: Because I need to reuse them in
>> Casey: other new overloads for P1206.
>> Stephan: AH OK,
that's definitely an
argument to keep them separate.
Yeah, Casey says merge conflicts.
Merge conflicts everywhere.
I have some cleanup to do well
that lives up to your nickname.
Back when we installed offices,
you and Billy had so you were
constantly working on code making
so many cool improvements,
but you're constantly merge conflicting.
So I put a little post notes
over your names on your door
saying Billy merge O'Neill.
And Casey conflict Carter.
So there you go.
Merge conflicts everywhere.
OK, so we were in assign
forward range I was checking in the new size.
This is a size type new size
so the type is the same one.
If I see code being transformed like this
I want to make sure we're not changing
the types of variables or things like that.
It's always going to be
initialized ifdef concepts.
Then here.
if constexpr(forward_iterator)
OK, same pattern as before.
Then again, this convert size will
need to be changed ranges distance,
and that's all good.
Otherwise exactly the same as before.
Yep.
And then the caller ifdef concepts
constexpr bool _Is_fwd
This has occurred twice.
If it occurred many more times,
there would be an argument for extracting
this into a variable template.
If we could find like a good
name with only two occurrences,
even though this is somewhat verbose,
I'm OK with this as is usually my rules.
Like once we see something
repeated three times,
that's an argument to extract
2 times is not quite enough.
If extracting would be annoying.
The argument there would be.
Yeah, we'd loot the one.
The one thing if does.
I'm OK with this one more time.
I would ask for it to be lifted out.
OK, so if _Is_fwd_iter_v otherwise
or if it meets the forward_iterator concept.
So again this is being very cautious
about not disrupting existing code.
All the comments are good then if it is
forward to assign forward range with unwrapped,
otherwise assign input range unwrapped.
OK, that looks good. Uhm?
Oh, and here's the reason to have the
separate functions for assign, because we do.
Call the forward one only for init list,
so having a separate function
to call is very nice for input,
the arguments for Casey's code,
which is coming aside forward range of begin
and end aside forward range because we know.
Yeah, it's definitely random access.
OK, that looks good. Product code.
Aside from the conversion
of the size looks great.
OK, viewed. Test code.
Test code is tiny,
excellent. Fancy pointers.
We need to change this slightly because
let's see if I can intuit why. The
concept for the range is probably
inspecting operator plus plus and with
this fancy pointer we were like, OK,
we really never want to post increment.
That's why it was being deleted.
Here.
We actually do need to provide
it to meet the concept so.
We're just going to provide the basic
implementation operator++ returns by value.
Result is deref this.
Bringing our Rep OK, that's the variable.
Restoring and then return the
result by value the old result.
Yep, that looks good.
Sometimes this is written as
like plus plus deref this but
just directly saying plus plus
Rep is fine and more efficient.
Not that efficiency matters for this test.
Or sorry.
>> Casey: Go ahead and suggest it's possible that we
>> Casey: can have these explode on instantiation.
>> Casey: On if if we make these explode when
>> Casey: the function body is instantiated,
>> Casey: we might be able to still satisfy the
>> Casey: concepts by having the right declarations,
>> Casey: but also achieve the same end of ensuring
>> Casey: that our our implementation doesn't
>> Casey: use these by having them how about?
>> Stephan: How about just an assert false?
>> Stephan: Or would you want like a static
>> Stephan: assert of blah blah?
>> Casey: Yeah, static assert always false what I was thinking
>> Stephan: OK, is this thing templated?
It is indeed.
And let's say oh, it's a compile only
test so hi wouldn't get us very far.
>> Casey: So if it's a compiler test,
>> Casey: these probably don't need to
>> Casey: have function bodies.
>> Stephan: Oh yeah, just semi-colons right
>> Stephan: actually, none of these really need,
and they're not constexpr,
so we couldn't be evaluated.
Yeah, I wonder why we went to the.
To bother.
Yeah, because we're not
actually going to execute code.
The internal test harness we'll
try to run the empty main,
but in no event will any of
this stuff be instantiated.
Yeah, why do we go to all this effort?
So would you still want the static
asserts to make sure that we're not
actually instantiating this stuff?
>> Casey:Yeah, it would be nice.
>> Stephan: OK.
>> Stephan: UM? OK, I will add first check.
Yeah predac.
OK,
that's all good.
OK. See.
Although.
Post increment and post decrement need to
exist in order to satisfy the concept. Umm?
Casey Carter notes that we'd still like
to avoid actually using these operations.
In the product code. It should be
sufficient to add a
static assert Ohh Casey remarks we
do need bodies since the internal
test runner links compile only tests.
Yeah, this would attempt to link.
If it if we instantiate code
that calls fancy pointer stuff,
they need to link to the function.
Bodies do need to exist,
but Casey knows they don't need
to do actually useful work here.
It's reasonable to provide
useful work anyways.
It should be sufficient
to add a static assert.
Should we just use the internal
always false or?
Should we recommend anything specific here?
>> Casey: I'm pretty sure we do use
>> Casey: it in test somewhere else.
>> Stephan: We can check
>> Casey: so it would be consistently
>> Casey: wrong.
>> Casey: Or do we always define... I know there's one in
>> Stephan: No, we don't
>> Casey: algorithm support.
>> Casey: We always define the local one.
>> Stephan: Yeah, we define a local always
false in yeah, the algo support.
Or null forward iterators.
This is the classic type I guess the.
constexpr bool always_false = false; is  the cooler one to depict.
When I show that range algorithm
support test include.
tests, std, include.
range algorithm support background here
For those who are unfamiliar
with this fun bit of standardese
is that if you just say
static assert false in a template,
the compiler is permitted to say
ha, that will never compile and
just fill your compile dead,
which is not what you want you.
You basically always want a static
assert false to be enforced on demand
when The thing is actually instantiated.
I believe there's work in the
committee happening right now
to actually make that a reality,
which will be awesome so that
we don't need to define these
inline constexpr bools all the time.
Hopefully that might even be applied
as defect report one could hope.
OK, so let's recommend this.
It should be sufficient to add a
static assert with an always false helper.
Then this would fail to compile
if any product code attempted to
instantiate operator or post increment.
Post meowcrement but the
function signatures will still be
visible for the purpose of the concepts.
OK, how does this look?
Casey notes it is P2593,
allowing static assert false.
I can show that. Link
P2593.
Yeah, allowing static_assert(false)
by Barry Revzin,
who has proposed other awesome
standard features like constexpr
bool, sorry explicit bool which
is an incredible help in tuple
and pair and things like that.
So thank you Barry for that paper.
OK so although post increment
and post decrement need to exist
in order to satisfy the concept,
Casey notes that we'd still like
to avoid actually using these
operations in the product code.
It should be sufficient to add a static.
assert with an always false helper blah,
then this would fail to compile
if any product code attempted
to instantiate postmeowcrement,
but the function signatures will still
be visible for the purpose of the concepts.
OK.
Cameron notes I can hear John John Caves.
I presume, crying over the
paper because he did so much
compiler work to ensure we error.
Check nondependent static assert false cases.
Yeah, the compiler went to so much effort
and then we're just gonna wash it all away.
OK, and that's the only
product code change needed,
because this is a performance change.
We have existing code that
already exercises vector of
input iterator forward iterator.
I wonder if we should ask for test
coverage to exercise the new code path,
not necessarily the check here,
but just the essentially along
the lines of the original code,
just to make sure we're instantiating,
I think I would want to see that.
Because if the danger is always.
What about stealth build breaks where we
do something that looks like it compiles,
but the moment you instantiated it fails.
Where's a good test to add that?
It would be ranges,
but is there a good ranges
test where? ranges transform maybe?
because the original code
involved to transform.
Yeah.
Even yeah, even something
very very similar to this,
you know, slightly cleaned up.
Would be reasonable. OK, so that
would that be ranges algo transform.
Let's see if we can find that test
>> Casey: p0896 ranges algo transform, yeah?
>> Stephan: There are two. There is unary and
binary. This would be the unary 1.
And we do use what views?
Oh, we don't test the view here.
Here we just say std::transform or
something. Can't type transform.
Here we're just calling we're
we're not using the view.
Is there a separate test for the views?
>> Casey: You mean the transform view?
>> Stephan: Yeah, the transform view.
>> Casey:it would be 0896R4
>> Casey: views transform
>> Stephan: views transform OK,
>> Stephan: that's the one I wanted because in this
case it's is it the view that spits
out the iterator that we care about.
Because if we just run it through the.
Function object ish thing that
actually does the transform.
It doesn't doesn't emit iterators.
Or am I completely confused?
>> Casey: We we want to use views transform
>> Casey: the function object to this thing
>> Casey:and it will pick the proper
>> Stephan: yeah
>> Casey: specialization of transform view.
>> Stephan: OK, but the other one.
The ranges transform that wouldn't
>> Stephan: be what we want, right?
>> Casey: Right
>> Casey: that's just an algorithm.
>> Stephan: Yeah,
OK, yeah, just that would actually physically
do the transformation in place right?
Not not emit the view.
OK, so this is the one we want to ask for.
Basically yeah, just depend to the test.
Yeah, just add to main.
Yeah, I think this is a good ask for.
OK so.
I'll just link main here. Maybe
permalink hit Y there is the main.
OK, and where's a good place to ask?
Maybe just at the test.
I really want the ability to like add
comments that are not attached
to any specific line.
I guess the product code too.
Yeah cause it's not specific tests.
I'll add it to the end of the product code.
OK. Umm? It would be good to add
a small amount of test coverage
to exercise these new code paths
I'd recommend. Adding. This to.
The end of main in. Views transform.
And let's cite AlexBAV's code here.
It should be sufficient
to use code like. The.
Like the original report.
Like the original test case in. 1709
but also. Calling was it?
Covering
the constructor, insert  and assign
Honestly, if they're like instantiated,
that's good enough for me.
Probably just checking that
the values that are value gets
into the vector is good enough.
Uhm
Asserting that one. Element.
Asserting that one element is
successfully transformed each
time should be sufficient to.
Verify that we've. Successfully.
Stored elements in the
vector. OK, it would be good to add
a small amount of test coverage
to exercise these new code paths.
I'd recommend adding this to the
end of main in views transform blob.
It should be sufficient to use
code like the original test case
in 1709 covering the constructor,
insert and assign asserting that one
element is successfully transformed
each time should be sufficient
to verify that we've successfully
stored elements in the vector.
I mean, maybe add the rationale.
This will ensure.
That there are no stealth
build breaks compiler warnings.
Or compiler bugs always got to
worry about the compiler bugs
with this advanced concept stuff.
And the new.
This will ensure that there are no
stealth build breaks, compiler warnings,
or compiler bugs in the new code.
Yeah, just a good habit to get into that.
Try to instantiate all the new stuff
that you write, because even if like
99% of the time it works 1% of time.
Oh, there's a compiler bug that
nobody would have thought of.
Or oh, we forgot to assign.
Not usually that bad these days, but a
compiler warning like truncation or whatever.
Very easy to encounter.
So a little bit of test coverage
would be good.
OK, so three comments
1) dealing with the size,
2) add a little bit of test coverage.
3) add the static assert.
Otherwise this looks good to go.
I like it.
OK, so I think we can
mark all this as viewed.
And this is changes requested.
This is close enough that we
could even just push changes.
And move it forward.
I think I know exactly what I
want to see here. I could just
push changes and that way.
Expedite this for merging because
I think this should be ready to
merge once these changes are made.
This is one of our older PRs.
We're really trying to
clear the the PR backlog.
I think I'll do that when changes need
more when they're more open ended,
and we're not sure exactly
what should be done.
Giving the contributor chance to
read the feedback and think about
how they like to handle it is good.
But these are so targeted
now mostly pretty tiny.
This PR is really high quality.
I think I can just go ahead and
push changes so I will hold off
and actually submitting this.
I'll make the changes.
I'll push it and then speed this
forward to final review later
and then this should be actually
possibly even ready to go in the
next batch of PRs that we merge.
So I think that does it for this review.
Are there any other questions I don't
haven't seen any accumulated in the the chat?
I think we were able to look at
a bunch of cool stuff in vector.
And I've learned some things about
how the concepts world works as well,
slowly catching up to all the stuff
that they've added in C++20 and now 23.
So.
OK.
Cameron says my first question
isn't directly related to this PR.
It's OK if something comes up that
makes you wonder what's going on.
Then it is cool to talk about.
Oh, here we go.
Here's the question. Cameron asks.
So you noted earlier that the STL is
greatly favoring if constexpr as the
method of dispatching versus tag dispatch.
There's an implied behavior change here,
and that is that the old tag dispatch
behavior worked by best match.
Well, if constexpr works by first match
has the STL observed this behavior changed?
It's an excellent question,
so Cameron is asking is that let me
see if I can maybe just sketch something.
I will actually try to compile it.
So. If you have something like uhm.
Let's add some template stuff so it's
vaguely realistic template type name.
Iter void helper taking Iter, it and then.
input
iterator tag that's then going to do stuff.
Like this?
And then replicate several different ways.
Forward. Bidirectional.
And random access something like
this versus the new World order
of template type name iter.
void do_stuff taking the iter it,
and then we would have if constexpr and I
can actually bring up the definition of
_Is_fwd_iter_v because this is
not what one would always expect.
UM, where do we define it?
xutility, we ask,
is_convertible and not is_base_of
because is_base_of will return true
even for things that are ambiguous,
is_convertible as essentially very similar
to what we were doing with tag dispatch.
So if we were to hand write this.
This is a course also an internal helper.
I can show the definition of that _Iter_cat_t
Is not actually referencing my
favorite animal, but it's asking
what is the iterator category.
So if we were to fully expand this thing out.
Do a little bit of copy pasting
here make this somewhat realistic.
OK like that.
And I can actually look this out.
We could let's make this fully realistic,
so. Do a little copy pasting.
Yeah, looks good.
Multi cursor editing. I love it. OK.
This last one is really an implied else,
so we can go like this.
OK, so Cameron's question is,
there's an implied behavior
change here when you had.
Let me show the new stuff too.
This is old. This is new.
Helper of iter and category brace brace.
Just make A tag type or object of that tag
type versus the new way of doing things.
So in the old way we're asking the
compiler hey, do overload resolution.
We're going to give you an object of this
tag type and choose the best match here.
Sometimes this could even involve
a conversion, for example in the
vector case we only care about.
Are you input only or are
you stronger than forward?
So if you have a random access iterator
tag and these let me comment these out.
If categories are random access iterator tag,
you would need a conversion
to call both of these.
But thanks to the core language,
which is awesome.
The conversion from random access
iterator tag to its base class
forward iterator tag is better,
meaning less severe than the conversion
all the way up to its even higher
base class input iterator tag.
So this is more preferred
if you have an random access.
iterator,
which is exactly the behavior that we want,
so that overload resolution is
happening all at once in some sense.
But if you have if constexpr now,
you have essentially classic control flow,
you can control the order
in which things are tested.
Here we test random access iterator.
1st and so forth.
But if we had done this the other way,
I mean,
just reverse this for the sake of exposition.
This would not have the same
effect if we test bidirectional first,
this would activate and absorb random
access iterators and we would never
get a chance for this to be correct.
So to answer Cameron's question,
have we ever observed a behavior change here?
The answer is no,
because we have always been very
careful when transforming old tag
dispatch to new if constexpr.
We're very careful to test
things in the correct order.
Not this order,
but the original order where
we test the most specific thing
first and then gradually test to
more and more general things,
which exactly replicates the behavior
that we wanted from the old tag dispatch.
Essentially the what the STL does,
although we could do a lot
of things with tag dispatch,
we generally only do two things.
The most one of the most popular
is testing on iterator strength,
where iterators fall into this.
Power hierarchy and we can test from
strongest to weakest or we all.
We have a lot of yes,
no tests like is this thing a map
versus a set? Is it trivial or not?
Is it copy constructible or not?
Only occasionally do we have something
even more complicated like think I
think one of the most complicated
ones I can think of is a vector
reallocation where we need a three part test.
Are you noexcept movable?
If you're not,
are you copy constructible?
well,
then you're throw movable and we'll
just move you and hope there's no exceptions.
And so in that one actually,
if constexpr is much more natural
because we do want that sequencing
compared to tag dispatch where we
had to sort of enforce sequencing
with a specific pattern of true false
and true type and false type parameters.
So it is something to keep in mind.
But if constexpr is actually
completely fine,
as long as we're careful about the
order in which things are tested.
Really,
it hasn't really been an issue because
the nice thing is that because if
constexpr looks like control flow,
all of our intuitions for
testing things in the correct
order completely apply. If anything,
it's the sort of unsorted nature of
overload resolution that makes things
a little bit harder and scary, right?
Like here, when I look at
this classic tag dispatch.
Overload set I'm not too worried
because I see this pattern.
I know how it works,
but if it gets more complicated
with we've got like ones that
were like true type false type,
any tag where any tag was like
convertible from anything there
we really need to sit down and
think real hard about OK does this
produce you know unambiguous results
for every possible combination,
but when we have if constexpr
we can just say OK,
we're going to test the thing we
care about first otherwise then
we've sort of examined that thing
we no longer need to worry about it.
It's much more than methodical.
So I would say the changes there
have been entirely positive,
but it is something to worry about.
OK and yeah, Casey says in fairness,
the vast majority of our tag
dispatch is only two cases,
true type and false type.
>> Casey: Yeah,
>> Casey: we haven't had a whole lot of
>> Casey: opportunities to screw up.
>> Stephan: OK so I will go ahead and push
changes to this PR later and thanks
to Adam Bucior for this excellent PR
that will improve the performance
of using C++20 ranges with the
most popular container in the STL.
I did not even realize this was an issue
because I would look at the old code.
I'd be like ohh _Is_fwd_iter_v?
Yeah that's going to tag forward
iterators and yeah concept should
be fine but the STL is always
full of surprises so thanks and I
think we'll see you next time on
the VC libraries Open code review.